les partis politiques préparent
activement la campagne des élections des
4 et 11 mars et ils mettent en ce moment
au point la tactique ils vont employer
lors des deux tours de scrutins des
prochaines législatives au terme de 2
jours de réflexion de son comité central
le Parti communiste confirme qu'il
défendra ses candidats et son
originalité au premier tour au deuxème
tour il encouragera le rassemblement de
la gauche qui a un programme commun de
gouvernement nous avons appelé notre
parti à un immense effort à une campagne
sans précédent pour pour rassembler dès
le premier tour des élections puisque au
premier tour on choisit et au deuxème on
élimine donc pour rassembler au premier
tour sur les candidats de notre parti le
plus grand nombre de voix poss possible
les raisons en sont simples les partis
communiste les candidats du Parti
communiste sont les défenseurs constants
des intérêts des travailleurs et des
masses populaires comme le montre toute
leur
expérience en second lieu le Parti
communiste entend agir pour la mise en
application des dispositions contenu
dans le programme commun en faveur des
travailleurs et des masses populaires et
disons en premier lieu les objectifs
sociaux en trisè lieu enfin nous
entendons vrer pour renforcer et
développer l'Union des Force Ouvrière
démocratique et nationale l'entente
entre partis de gauche pour la rendre
irréversible